[Music]
afghanistan is spinning out of control
our documents being shredded how are
things being secured we are going to
continue to have a diplomatic presence
on the ground in afghanistan but we are
reducing the size of our civilian
footprints given the evolving security
situation there
afghanistan is on course to witness the
highest ever number of documented
civilian casualties in a single year
since the u.n records began these
soldiers and marines that are fully
kitted out
putting on night vision goggles landing
in kabul taking positions at the airport
they're going to a combat zone are they
not
they're certainly going into harm's way
lucas
let's bring in our panel molly hemingway
senior editor at the federalist charles
lane opinion writer for the washington
post and steve hayes editor of the
dispatch welcome to you all one month
ago today molly not today but but one
month ago maybe a few days after that it
seems that that president biden said it
was highly unlikely that the taliban
would take over in afghanistan today
congressman mark greene of tennessee
also an afghan vet he said this watch
the truth of the matter is is this
surprised them that they they were not
expecting this no one in congress was
briefed this was going to happen uh
they they got caught with their pants
down no outcome has to be inevitable
here i'm not going to
speculate about surprise we're obviously
watching this just like you're watching
this and seeing it happen in real time
and it's deeply concerning
he wouldn't speculate about surprise but
it sure appeared to be a surprise molly
your thoughts
the pundits and media and politicians
are talking about the incompetence of
the exit or how surprised they are about
what it's like to leave afghanistan but
they shouldn't be surprised this is the
natural result of 20 years of failed
strategy
they should be talking about the
incompetence of the strategy that this
country used for two decades we went
from using our military to fight and win
wars into the impossible task of nation
building when we were attacked on 9 11
we needed to have a swift and serious
response we did that but then president
bush took his eyes off the ball he got
mired in in the iraq war he and cheney
and obama and biden then took on this
task of nation building in afghanistan
the country historians call the
graveyard of empires that is what people
need to focus on so that we never do it
again when our military is used we need
to have clear strategic objectives we
need to get in and get out and that is
what people don't want to talk about but
it's the most important lesson to learn
right now yeah she makes a good point
steve because you know the idea really
was after 9 11 you go in and you attack
the people that attacked you and then it
was about democracy building hopefully
their their thought was that was going
to stop al qaeda from coming back in and
here we are 20 years later and it seems
like the door is back open for al qaeda
to come back in steve your thoughts
yeah it sure does well al-qaeda never
left afghanistan look it's important to
have a big discussion about the overall
strategy and i think there are plenty of
ways in which the strategy in
afghanistan failed over the past two
decades but it definitely matters uh if
the biden administration was surprised
by the swiftness of the taliban advance
you know you've you've had statements
from biden administration officials in
recent days that are very close to
baghdad bob territory you had ned price
you just played a clip of him a moment
ago
saying last week that that the taliban
want a durable solution through
negotiations there's no evidence
whatsoever that the taliban want a
durable solution through negotiations
you've had other senior administration
officials talking about how the united
states would threaten
to isolate the taliban if it takes
afghanistan by force the taliban isn't
worried about being isolated and by the
way as this is all unfolding the taliban
can look next door to iran which is the
world's greatest state sponsor of terror
who's continuing to conduct attacks
against americans and our interests
and we're not isolating iran we're
inviting iran to be part of the world
community so the the arguments that
you're getting from the biden
administration suggest that they were
surprised by this because they're so
incoherent yeah and it's not fair to say
chuck that that john kirby wouldn't use
the word combat but boy he was really
hesitant i want to watch this back and
forth with he and lucas tomlinson get
your response
do you consider this a combat mission
this is a very narrowly focused
uh mission of of safeguarding the
orderly reduction of civilian personnel
out of afghanistan marines and the
soldiers that are about to strap it on
going to kabul and this is in combat
lucas what i'm telling you is and i've
said it before they will have the
ability to defend themselves
they're trying to fly civilians chuck
out of what used to be kabul
international airport right and the
taliban is maybe hours or days away from
taking over it sure looks like this
could become a combat mission
it could a great question that i think
no one knows the answer to is what's
more in the taliban's interest to stand
back for a while and let the americans
go peacefully
so they don't risk a retaliation from
these very capable u.s troops or to
somehow engage them and bloody them and
try to embarrass them further and make
things even more difficult for president
biden i just want to go back to what
molly said you know with her
second guessing and so forth of this
mission
and focus on today and what is happening
today what is happening today whether
you like it or not whether we should
have been there or not
is that thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands of people who depended on us
are now left high and dry and exposed to
tremendous potential reprisals and
violence at the hands of this
extreme islamist group number one and
number two allies all over the world
japan korea
the middle east latin america are all
asking themselves today
are we going to end up like these folks
in kabul maybe highly imperfect and so
forth but put their trust in the united
states and at the end of the day one
fine day the president said contrary to
the advice of my military advisers who
tell me that with just 2 500 troops we
can make a go of it we're leaving
yeah and molly i mean you you can
respond to that i mean these people
these interpreters these people who we
depended on for years need to get out
we're trying right now to get them out
it's absolutely true that the pentagon
did not make good exit plans in part
because they were trying to trick
president biden into staying there
that's what our pentagon has done that
is how they've been able to keep people
there but the fact is that rather than
focusing on what's in the taliban's
interest we need to be thinking about
what's in our interest it is not in our
interest to spend trillions of dollars
20 decades or 20 years and all of the
lives that we lost for a mission that
couldn't even be sustained for a few
days without that level of support here
we go quickly winners and losers steve
my winner are air conditioner repairmen
with nearly half of the country under
excessive heat watch they've been
awfully busy lately and i think are
making some good bucks my loser
uh is david mickelson the head of the
left-leaning fact-checking outfit snopes
who was busted with more than 60
articles of plagiarism plagiarism used
to be a capital offense people can
recover from it now but he should be
more than suspended in my view
chuck
my winner is the state of texas and the
republicans who currently run it they're
going to pick up uh they're confirmed to
pick up two seats in the house per the
census that came out this week
and call me captain obvious but my loser
this week is andrew cuomo the former
soon-to-be former governor of new york
forced to resign over the sexual
harassment case oh he did resign you
thank you molly you last
my winner our parents who are taking on
the school boards were pushing bad ideas
such as critical race theory and other
racist ideas on their children my loser
secretary mayorkas who is overseeing the
humanitarian disaster at the border
caused by the biden administration's
policies thank you all hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else